hey what's the idea blocking traffic
somebody's gonna get hurt well cabbie is
a real welcome to my home this is my
cartoon theater where I show cartoons
just it's getting further and further
along the delusion spectrum for me
anyway thanks for kind of thanks for
coming to my cartoon theater so this
this cartoon I want to show you so
originally there was Gulliver's Travels
which is an animated 1939 and then there
was a there was a town crier yeah and
the Fleischer brothers it's weird that
names are starting to ring a bell I'm
like yeah the Fleischer's yeah okay the
Fletcher brothers thought that this this
Gabby character was gonna be a breakout
animated star sure so they decided to do
a cartoon starring Gabby and not a big
hit so soon after that this the
Fleischer brothers were fired okay so
they really put a lot on Gabby
yeah Gabby did not work out for them
Gabby killed them basically anyway happy
birthday any depressing details you want
others just the positive ones
make me feel good what is this called
this is called - for the zoo fired up
Jimbo you know there was a Jimmy which
there isn't I don't think it's right to
call him Jimbo Gabby yep I already this
is like making a movie with Jar Jar
Binks
what's not to love you see how funny it
[Music]
can go in there
what's the king of do you think well
Gabby is a real yeah
very rare it's not that rare what's the
thing you know what would you start your
questions with hey you're a dick
well good thing you ran into an idiot
yeah okay so here's the thing
kangaroos get mad if you say they don't
exist I'll tell you what all right whoa
[Music]
you see a problem oh yeah I just want
you to picture the Fleischer brothers in
a room together gun-like yeah yeah okay
yeah like that I feel like we got some
trajectory but the key imagine thinking
this character is something that people
would want to watch oh no I mean he's
annoying he's grading he steals this is
when people picture the ugly American
they picture Gabby there's a kangaroo do
you think it's possible that the flesh
of others didn't know what a kangaroo
was yeah I mean in this day and age sure
so this is water rubberneck tango was
like if I couldn't see it with my own
eyes we don't need all these he breaks
the third law I don't like that he does
this I don't want to Gaby aside
I mean this might just be the regular
defecation process of a kanga they knew
how to get the most out of a moment the
flashers absolutely am I gonna see a
kanga barf I mean I just I'm so over
Gabby it's just so was everyone in the
theater yeah and I mean you're talking
about a time in the theaters when it's
like if there was something on the
screen people to watch it and they were
still like nah I guess I will go to the
lobby and get myself a snack I told my
kid Etta they were there were cartoons
before every movie and he almost lost
his mom yeah what what yeah yeah now we
have commercials they really pulled one
over on us
however I would rather watch any
commercial really than see Gabby
meanwhile this is it's amazing up keep
the bucket on Gabby's head forever so he
shouldn't eat those they shouldn't be in
this climate this is the attitude some
people have towards climate change the
animals there in front of them those
yeah I'm not buying it I can't
it's amazing to me how much it looks
exactly like a kangaroo so he had a cage
just in case so he's just out in the
woods Silence of the lambing it some
weirdo
[Music]
[Applause]
I just I I'm looking for a redeeming
quality in Gabby it has not dawned on
Gabby yet that there are two instead of
it being the incredible shrinking and
growing Kengo now I can see to you hey
wait a minute how come you got a slit in
your belly Gabby's attitude to
everything but you can see now why the
fleshy brother saw this character more
like this is the next big thing yeah
either they got fired now it's shocking
ah he just liked himself
so he dies in him I'm happy that he gets
killed by a lion I would have liked to
have seen it though right yeah just
tearing him apart and bloody yeah yeah
just slowly screaming dying god
damn he's a beating that might be the
worst most grating cartoon character
I've seen every moment that happens he
meets with pure animosity and resistance
yeah that's what got the Fleischer
brothers - Wow they got killed they
killed themselves
no the Paramount had the murder what
yeah it's is that serious yeah yeah
after that came out no they fired him
and then they drove out to the desert
and they shot over the back of the head
and you know what they said well you
know what the last words were why we dig
our own graves what's a big idea hey
what's the idea was killing us pop pop
oh that was more depressing than climate
change it's tough to say but it's
certainly close I would say if climate
change were to take human form it would
be Gabby
[Music]